at some point in the spring of 2019 I
noticed that my apartment had received
some unexpected visitors
they likely arrived not through the door
but through the window and for a long
time I didn't know they were there it
was not until I happened to see the
fronds of a mosque growing in a
pig-shaped ceramic planter next to the
window that I had any idea we'd been
invaded
the Moss spores took up residence around
a tiny bunny ear cactus a friend who's
here given me for my birthday years
earlier
I'd always hated how cold and damp the
area next to my kitchen window was it
never gets any sun and the cactus
probably did too but the moss found it
hospitable
it's set about dividing differentiating
grabbing hold of the potting soil with
hair like rhizoids and growing tiny
green leaves
then it sent up long slender sporophytes
ready to continue the same process as
its ancestors outside the apartment
soon a miniature forest was fairly
bursting from the top of the pig
compared to vascular plants mosses have
a relatively unmediated relationship to
Water and Air
in her book Gathering Moss Robin wall
kimmerer notes that the one cell sick
leaves of mosses are like the alveoli of
human lungs given that they require
moisture and come into direct contact
with air
on Antarctica which has no trees
scientists have used mosses in a similar
manner to tree rings the Mosses are
capable of laying down a record each
summer because of the way their leaves
take in chemicals from the surroundings
growing from their tips
sitting in my kitchen I obviously could
not read the record that this errant
Moss was writing but it did at least
tell me I'm alive and the next day still
alive
Ivy red Gathering Moss during the early
lockdowns of the covid-19 pandemic
time felt Frozen then but the Moss kept
growing both inside and outside the
apartment and the pandemic had Shrunk
the scale of my attention
I walked around Oakland like a
pedestrian conspiracy theorist peering
at things from odd angles
Moss loved the interstices which meant
it was often exactly where I wouldn't
think to look
between cracks in the walkway outside my
apartment between the asphalt of the
road and the manhole cover between the
grocery store wall and the sidewalk
between bricks
I came to understand Moss as the
signature of water both in placement and
appearance as it grew wherever water had
collected in the past but it also
answered the rain in real time expanding
and turning Greener within minutes of a
light shower the Moss made me consider
both very short time scales like the
minute to minute changes in moisture or
the moment of a Spore growing in my
planter and very long evolutionary time
scales as mosses were some of the very
first plants to live on land
yet both ends of the temporal Spectrum
were also reminders of how impossible it
is to pinpoint a moment a very human
thing to want to do on one end for
example I found disagreement about when
a mossport has officially germinated is
it when it has become swollen with water
to a certain degree or when the germ
tube forms and the cell cell wall
ruptures
on the other end the earliest mosses
evolved from aquatic algae at some point
hundreds of millions of years ago but it
would be absurd to try to identify the
exact moment of this Innovation or even
the speciation of the guest on my
windowsill
this slipperiness easily spilled over
into other questions
could a moss be meaningfully separated
from its surroundings
was a moss Spore considered alive
what about a moss that was frozen like
the one in Antarctica that was brought
back to life after 1500 years
even outside extreme conditions mosses
complicate the idea of uniform time with
the ability of some species to go
dormant for more than a decade without
water
under the right circumstances they will
revive
it was this very quality as Cameron
mentioned in a 2020 interview in the
believer that made Moss especially worth
paying attention to during the covid-19
pandemic noting that her students took
inspiration from Ross's rootedness and
dormancy camera suggested that these
plants could teach humans how to inhabit
this historical moment
the Moss arrived in my apartment around
the time I started thinking about this
book it was still growing when I
finished
true it probably will not live in that
spot for 5 000 years as has one moth
shelf on Elephant Island also in
Antarctica
but in the long mean time it has taken
in three years of sunlight breezed three
years of air and witnessed three years
of me at the kitchen table
like an emissary from somewhere outside
clock time it has populated my mind with
questions of porousness and response of
inside and outside of potentiality and
imminence
most of all it has been a reminder of
time not the monolithic empty substance
imagined to wash over each of us alone
but the kind that starts and stops
bubbles up collects in the cracks and
folds into mountains
it is the kind that waits for the right
conditions that holds always the ability
to begin something new
[Music]